Me perguntaram faz poucos dias, vale
usar os sacaromices bullard para não ter
diarreia ao tomar antibiótico? Eu vou te
contar uma história que aconteceu no meu
consultório há algumas semanas e que me
fez ter certeza absoluta de que preciso
falar sobre isso com vocês. Chegou uma
paciente, vamos chamá-la de Maria com
aquela cara de quem está cansada de
médico. Sabe aquela expressão? Ela tinha
tomado três ciclos de antibiótico nos
últimos seis meses. Cada vez que
terminava um, a diarreia batia forte. E
aí o que que acontece? Ela volta no
médico que prescreve outro antibiótico
achando que é uma nova infecção. Virou
um ciclo vicioso danado. Quando ela me
contou isso, eu pensei: "Caramba, mais
uma vítima de um erro que poderia ter
sido evitado lá no primeiro
antibiótico." Você direto com vocês. A
gente vive num sistema de saúde que
trata sintoma e não causa. E tem um
negócio chamado sacarumicesis blarde,
que poderia ter poupado a Maria de meses
de sofrimento, mas ninguém falou para
ela sobre isso. Sabe por quê? Porque não
está na bula do antibiótico, porque o
laboratório que vende antibiótico não
ganha nada para escrever no proteção
junto. É simples assim, bizarro, né? Mas
é a realidade crua que a gente vive.
Deixa eu te explicar o que acontece
quando você toma um antibiótico. Imagina
o seu intestino como uma floresta
tropical. Tem milhões de bichinhos lá
dentro trabalhando direitinho, cada um
com a sua função. Agora, quando você
tomou antibiótico, é como se jogasse um
herbicida nessa floresta. O antibiótico
não é seletivo, entende? Ele não mata só
a bactéria ruim que tá causando a sua
infecção na garganta ou no pulmão. Ele
passa como um rolo compressor e vai
matando tudo que é bactéria pelo
caminho, incluindo as bactérias boas do
seu intestino. E aí, meu amigo, minha
amiga, a casa cai. Estudos recentes de
2024, 2025 mostram que entre 17 e 40%
das pessoas desenvolve diarreia quando
tomam antibiótico. Isso significa que a
cada 10 pessoas tomando antibiótico,
quatro vão ter problema. Mas tem um
detalhe ainda mais sinistro. Mesmo quem
não tem diarreia pode estar
desenvolvendo uma desbiosa silenciosa.
Essa é a expressão técnica para dizer
que a sua flora intestinal ficou
bagunçada, só que você não sente nada de
imediato. Mas lá na frente isso pode
virar fadiga crônica, problemas de
imunidade, ganho de peso, problema de
pele, a conta sempre chega. Agora aqui
entra os sacarames bullard, que a gente
pode chamar carinhosamente de S Bulard.
Esse nome complicado é de uma levedura,
um tipo de fungo do bem, que tem uma
característica fantástica.
Ela não é bactéria. E por que que isso
importa? Porque os antibióticos matam
bactérias e não fungos. Então você pode
tomar o S bouard junto com o antibiótico
que ele não vai ser destruído. É como
ter um soldado que sobrevive à batalha.
justamente porque tá vestindo uma
armadura diferente. Deixa eu te mostrar
os números que eu sei que vocês gostam
de ver evidência. Uma metaanálise
gigantesca analisou 21 estudos com quase
5.000 participantes. E o resultado, quem
tomou o S bllar de reduziu o risco de
diarré de 18 para 8%.
Isso é uma redução de mais de 50%.
Em termos práticos, a cada 10 pessoas
que usam S blard preventivamente, uma é
poupada da diarreia. Parece pouco,
multiplica isso pela quantidade de
antibióticos prescritos por ano no
Brasil. E você vai ver que estamos
falando de milhões de pessoas que
poderiam estar protegidas. Mas a coisa
vai muito além de evitar diarreia.
Estudos europeus dos últimos 2 anos
demonstraram que o S Bard tem vários
mecanismos de ação bem bacanas.
Primeiro, ele se liga direto os
patógenos ruins, tipo um ímã grudando em
metais. Segundo, ele reduz a inflamação
local no seu intestino. Terceiro, isso
aqui é show, ele estimula as bactérias
boas que sobraram a produzirem ácido
gráso de cadeia curta. Esses aços são o
combustível das células do seu
intestino. É tipo dar uma injeção de
ânimo pra sua flora sobrevivente,
entende? E tem mais. O S bularde ajuda a
formar uma camada protetora no muco
intestinal. É como se ele criasse um
escudo protetor, onde as bactérias boas
podem se esconder e se recuperar
enquanto o antibiótico está fazendo o
trabalho dele lá na infecção que você
precisa tratar. Genial, né? Agora vamos
falar de dose porque isso é importante.
A maioria dos estudos usa entre 5 e 10
bilhões de unidades formadoras de
colônia por dia. O FC, que é basicamente
a quantidade de bichinhos vivos que você
tá tomando. Em termos práticos, isso
corresponde a 250 mg, a 1 g de S blard
por dia, dependendo da concentração do
produto. No Brasil, você encontra isso
com o nome comercial de florativ, mas
existem outras marcas também. E aqui vem
uma informação crucial que a maioria dos
médicos não sabe ou não fala. Quando
você deve tomar a visão integrativa mais
atual, baseada nos estudos europeus,
recomenda começar o S blard junto com
antibiótico. Isso mesmo, no mesmo dia. E
continuar pelo menos duas semanas depois
que o antibiótico acabar. Por quê?
Porque o estrago no seu intestino não
para quando você para o antibiótico. Seu
intestino precisa de tempo para se
recuperar e o S blard acelera essa
recuperação. Uma observação importante,
se você estiver tomando um probiótico,
tem bactérias, tipo lactobacilos ou
bífobactérium, aí sim você precisa dar
um intervalo de pelo menos duas a 3
horas do antibiótico,
porque senão o antibiótico vai matar
essas bactérias também. Mas o S Bard
como é fungo pode ser tomado junto. Essa
é uma das grandes vantagens dele.
Agora deixa eu te contar o que aconteceu
com a Maria. Lembra dela? Quando ela
começou o tratamento comigo, eu
prescrevi o antibiótico que ela
precisava para tratar a infecção que ela
tinha na época. Mas junto eu coloquei o
S Bulard. Pela primeira vez, seis meses,
ela não teve diarreia, zero, nada. E
mais, depois que terminamos o
tratamento, eu pedi para ela continuar o
S Bard por mais duas semanas. Três meses
depois, quando ela voltou paraa
reavaliação, ela estava outra pessoa,
mais energia, menos inchaço, intestino
funcionando como relógio suíço. Mas eu
quero que vocês entendam uma coisa, isso
não é mágica, é ciência, é abordagem
funcional, é olhar pro corpo como um
sistema integrado, onde cada parte afeta
a outra. O intestino não é só um tubo
que processa comida, ele é o centro do
seu sistema imunológico. 70% das suas
células de defesa estão lá. Quando você
destrói a flora intestinal, você está
desarmando o seu exército de defesa.
Pesquisadores na China e na Europa
fizeram estudos recentes em 2024 e 2025,
mostrando que o S Bulard não só previne
a diarreia, mas também ajuda a restaurar
grupos específicos de bactérias
benéficas, principalmente as famílias
lacnospiraceai
e ruminococacteai,
que são as grandes produtoras desses
ácidos grchos de cadeia curta que eu
mencionei. Sem essas bactérias, o seu
intestino fica vulnerável, inflamado,
permeável. Aí começa os problemas
autoimunes, as alergias e a fadiga
crônica. Tem gente que me pergunta: "Mas
doutor, se é tão bom assim, por que que
não está na bula do antibiótico? Por que
que meu médico não me falou?" E aí eu
respondo, porque o sistema não funciona
assim. Os laboratórios que fabricam
antibióticos ganham mais dinheiro quando
você volta com outro problema. É cruel
falar isso, mas é verdade. Não existe
incentivo financeiro para eles colocarem
na bula. Olha, tome isso aqui junto que
você não vai ter problema. Seria lindo,
mas não é assim que a banda toca. E tem
outro ponto. Na faculdade de medicina a
gente aprende muito pouco sobre
microbiota intestinal. Isso tá mudando
agora com a geração mais nova. Mas
médicos formados há 10, 15 anos atrás
não tiveram isso na grade curricular.
Então não é má fé do seu médico. Muitas
vezes ele simplesmente não sabe. Ele
aprendeu para escrever antibiótico e
ponto. Ninguém ensinou que junto vem um
protocolo de proteção. Na minha visão,
baseada em anos de prática e em
toneladas de literatura internacional,
todo antibiótico deveria vir
automaticamente acompanhado do S Bulard.
Deveria ser protocolo padrão, tipo soro
na sonda, sal na comida, deveria ser
óbvio, mas não é.
Enquanto isso não vira rotina, cabe a
você se informar e cobrar do seu médico.
Agora, um detalhe técnico importante, o
S Bulard não fica no seu intestino para
sempre. Ele é um visitante temporário.
Estudos mostram que ele alcança níveis
estáveis no intestino em cerca de três
dias de uso e desaparece completamente
das férias entre dois e 5 dias depois
que você para de tomar. Isso significa
que ele faz o trabalho dele e vai
embora. Não coloniza permanentemente.
Ele é tipo aquele amigo que te ajuda na
mudança e depois vai embora. não fica
morando na sua casa. Isso é bom, na
verdade, porque significa que você não
precisa tomar esse blard para sempre, só
durante logo após o antibiótico. Depois,
com a sua frada recuperada, seu próprio
intestino volta a funcionar sozinho como
deve ser. A ideia não é criar a
dependência de suplemento, mas dar um
suporte temporário pro seu corpo se
defender enquanto tá sobre ataque. Claro
que existe situações especiais, pessoas
imunocomprometidas, com catéter venoso
central ou com doenças intestinais
graves, preciso conversar com o médico
antes de usar qualquer probiótico,
inclusive o S bullard. Em casos
raríssimos, houve relatos de fungemia,
que é quando o fungo cai na corrente
sanguínea e se multiplica lá. Mas estou
falando de casos extremamente raros em
pessoas já muito debilitadas. Pra
população geral, o S Bard é considerado
seguro e bem tolerado. Agora pensa
comigo, quantos antibióticos você já
tomou na sua vida sem proteção nenhuma?
Pensa nos últimos 5 anos, será um, 2, 3.
Cada vez você fez isso, você deu um tiro
no pé da sua saúde intestinal. E o pior,
os efeitos são cumulativos. Cada vez que
você toma antibiótico sem proteção, fica
mais difícil pro seu intestino se
recuperar completamente. Até que um dia
ele não aguenta mais e começa os
problemas crônicos. Mas aqui vai a boa
notícia, nunca é tarde você começar a
fazer certo. Se você precisa tomar
antibiótico agora, você pode fazer
diferente, você pode proteger o seu
intestino. E se você já tomou
antibiótico no passado e tá sentindo
consequências agora, ainda dá tempo de
trabalhar na restauração da sua
microbiota. abordagem funcionais sobre
isso, dá pro corpo as ferramentas que
ele precisa para se curar. E vejo o caso
todos os dias de pessoas que passaram
anos sofrendo com sintomas que ninguém
conseguia explicar, fadiga, problemas de
pele, alergias que surgiram do nada,
ganho de peso inexplicável, depressão,
ansiedade. E quando a gente investiga lá
no histórico, tem três, qu cco ciclos de
antibiótico sem proteção alguma. É
coincidência? não é causa e
consequência. O intestino está mandando
sinais de socorro e ninguém está
ouvindo. Por isso eu insisto tanto nesse
tema, porque é algo relativamente
simples, barato, acessível, que pode
prevenir uma cascata de problemas no
futuro. É medicina preventiva de
verdade, não é só fazer checkup uma vez
por ano e achar que está tudo bem. É
entender como o corpo funciona e dar
suporte nos momentos críticos. E olha,
eu sei que muita gente vai assistir esse
vídeo e pensar: "Beleza, entendi, mas o
que que eu faço agora? Primeira coisa,
se você tá tomando antibiótico agora,
corre e compra esse bullard, começa
hoje, toma junto com antibiótico e
continua por duas semanas depois.
Segunda coisa, se você conhece alguém
que vai tomar antibiótico, passa essa
informação para essa pessoa, compartilhe
esse vídeo, faça o bem, pode ser que
você salve alguém de mesa e sofrimento,
como a Maria passou. Terceira coisa, da
próxima vez que o médico te prescrever
antibiótico, pergunta para ele sobre
problemas de microbiota. Se ele não
souber responder pro corto médico ou
pelo menos se informa e faz por conta
própria. E aqui vai minha opinião bem
direta. Nós precisamos parar de aceitar
passivamente o que o sistema de saúde
nos oferece. O sistema está quebrado,
está focado em vender remédio, não em
manter você saudável. Sua saúde é sua
responsabilidade. Nenhum médico vai
cuidar dela melhor do que você mesmo. O
médico pode te orientar, te dar
ferramentas, mas quem executa é você.
Quem faz as escolhas diárias é você.
Então, empodere-se, estude, pergunte,
questione, não aceite o não como
resposta quando se trata da sua saúde.